hi i'm lauren and today i'm becoming
black widow
what draws me personally to the
characters that i choose to cosplay has
always been
some sort of
shared connection that i have with that
character thinking about
her
where she's been who she is
and
appreciating her every step of the way
the same way
this character has helped me
learn to appreciate myself
over eight years i have
put together
25 or 26 different
looks
in a time in your life when you might
feel lost
and afraid and alone these films will
come along and they
will make you feel less alone you'll
also meet people in your life
who keep you going and who are your
avengers
the black widow community is
how
everyone shares everything even when
you're in a solitary creative process in
this hobby there is a sense of
collaboration because everyone wants to
share i had been a long time admirer of
lauren's work on the internet i was
really welcomed into the community
especially the black widow community on
instagram is
really supportive and that's how i met
lauren one of my most like awe-filled
moments was honestly when i saw lauren's
avengers 2012 suit
two of us coast to coast who are each
going to do
the very best version of this costume
that we absolutely can it really was
just about building each other up as
well as giving each other guidance i was
able to share what i had already learned
you know what i had the extra time to
research and to try out on my own i was
able to sort of pass that along to her
so that she could
also create you know the best possible
costume and i sketched it out i did a
flat sketch and illustrator of the
backpack and i was able to send that to
lauren to also help her with her
backpack honestly i never
could have made the backpack without
lauren's help i'm so grateful to her for
it because now that i've made it it is
one of my favorite parts of the costume
that i made i think this is the most
effort i've ever put into a build before
and i think it shows i hope it does and
i hope the other widow cosplayers
especially
love to see it
at the end of the day i just want to
share more love for natasha always if
you are
hesitating about putting yourself out
there and opening yourself up there will
be people here
to catch you the widows will always be
there
black widow but he's pg-13 experience it
now